.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Die Strandidylle trügt.
Ich bin in Estland,
in der Nähe zur russischen Grenze,
und erlebe, wie im Sommer 2022
aus einem harmlosen Gespräch
ein handfester Streit entstehen kann.
Ist es dieses Jahr hier anders
wegen der derzeitigen Situation?
Wenn es heiss ist ...
- (Mann) Sag nichts, lass das.
Ihr Mann will nicht?
- (Mürrisch) Nein, ich will nicht.
Er hat Angst, wir nicht.
Es gibt jetzt Kampfhandlungen
zwischen der Ukraine und Russland.
Na klar, das ist schlimm.
Ein Krieg bedeutet immer Dreck,
Mord, Grausamkeit, Verluste,
Verlust von Zuhause
und Verlust von Familienangehörigen.
Krieg ist etwas Furchtbares.
Und was meinen Sie, wer ist schuld?
Für mich sind beide Seiten schuld.
Wenn in einer Familie
gestritten wird:
Ist einer schuld oder beide?
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Guten Tag.
Wenn man Sie in Ihrem Land
überfällt, sagen Sie dann auch:
"Beide Seiten sind schuldig",
oder trägt nicht doch
der Angreifer Schuld?
Ich möchte mit Ihnen nicht
über dieses Thema sprechen.
Ich bin vor den Bomben geflohen,
vor dem Schrecken.
Wir fühlen mit Ihnen.
Nicht beide Seiten sind schuld.
Man hat unsere Städte überfallen.
Wo haben Sie gewohnt?
In Tschernigow,
an der Grenze zu Belarus.
Am 24. Februar begannen sie,
uns zu bombardieren.
Aber in Tschernigow war kein Krieg.
- Natürlich gab es.
Sind Sie verrückt?
Unglaublich, was Sie mir erzählen.
Die Hälfte der Stadt
existiert praktisch nicht mehr.
Ich musste flüchten.
Bei Belarus?
- Ja, an der Grenze zu Belarus.
So viele Menschen kamen ums Leben.
Ich bin aus Tschernigow,
und Sie wollen mir erklären,
dass es dort keinen Krieg gab.
Ich mache Ihnen ja keine Vorwürfe,
aber Sie glauben blind
an die Informationen,
die man Ihnen vorsetzt.
Vielleicht ist es eine Strafe,
eine Strafe Gottes.
Eine Strafe?
Sie meinen, wir haben es verdient?
Wahrscheinlich.
- Dafür werden Sie auch bestraft.
Wie kann man so grausam sein?
Ihr alle, die das unterstützt,
ihr seid auch verantwortlich -
für den Tod jedes Kindes.
(Mann)
Das ist doch reine Propaganda.
Ja, der Tod von Kindern,
das ist Propaganda.
Mein Name ist Christof Franzen.
Zehn Jahre lang
war ich Korrespondent in Moskau.
Jetzt bin ich unterwegs
im Grenzgebiet.
Auf der einen Seite Russland, auf
der anderen die Europäische Union -
die baltischen Staaten
Estland, Lettland und Litauen.
In diesem Film bereise ich
nicht nur zwei Seiten der Grenze,
ich reise auch in zwei Zeitaltern:
vor Beginn des Ukraine-Krieges
und danach.
2021 begegnete ich in dieser Region
bemerkenswerten Menschen.
In diesem Film zeige ich,
was sie damals sagten,
und will erfahren,
wie es ihnen heute geht.
Dabei erlebe ich auch
schockierende Sinneswandel.
Meine Reise im Herbst 2021
begann auf der russischen Seite,
in einem
geopolitisch bedeutenden Gebiet.
Hier ist die Grenze
zwischen Russland und dem Baltikum.
Das Gebiet, wo Russland
auf die NATO und die EU trifft.
Die erste Begegnung, die ich damals
hatte, war eine sehr angenehme.
Sehr angenehm, Christof. Guten Tag.
- Marina.
Ich traf auf Marina,
genannt die Storchen-Mutter.
Warum kümmern Sie sich um Störche?
Das ist eine lange Geschichte.
Sie begann vor etwa 20 Jahren.
Ich bin von Rostow am Don
ins Smolensker Gebiet umgezogen
und war so
von den Störchen fasziniert.
Ich kann es bis jetzt nicht fassen,
dass diese grossen schönen Vögel
neben den Menschen leben
und keine Angst vor ihnen haben.
Dort, wo ich früher gewohnt habe -
in der Grossstadt Rostow
im Süden Russlands -,
gab es keine Störche.
Es war ein rares Wunder.
Und hier sind es so viele.
Seit Jahren rettet Marina Störche,
die sich verletzt haben,
z.B. an Stromleitungen
oder auf der Strasse.
Nachdem sie in einer Fernsehshow
aufgetreten war,
erhielt sie mehrere Tausend Franken
Spendengelder.
Sie selber
schaue lieber kein Fernsehen mehr,
seither sei sie viel ruhiger.
Doch ganz ausblenden lässt sich die
Politik hier im Grenzgebiet nicht.
Hier ist doch Grenzgebiet.
Merkt man das?
Das merkt man. Ich denke, ab und zu
werden unsere Telefone abgehört.
Ernsthaft?
- Ja, es wird abgehört.- Natürlich.
Und das merkt man.
- Wisst ihr das etwa nicht?
Die Menschen sind sehr vorsichtig,
wenn sie ausländische
Autokennzeichen sehen.
Es gibt hier
ein freiwilliges Volksregiment.
Sie schauen,
dass hier alles in Ordnung ist
und berichten den Grenzschutztruppen
über alles.
Ihr werdet auch beobachtet,
auch wenn ihr wohl denkt,
dass sich hier keiner
für euch interessiert.
Hühnerköpfe für die Störche.
Für die Störche
ist die ganze Welt offen.
Sie kennen keine Grenzen.
Dumme Leute
haben sich Grenzen ausgedacht.
Sie führen ewige Kriege. Und wozu?
Man kann doch in Frieden leben,
Kinder grossziehen,
Getreide anbauen
und diese wunderbaren Vögel retten.
Was soll man da noch sagen?
Damals hätte ich mir
nicht träumen lassen,
was mich neun Monate später erwartet.
Am 24. Februar
marschierten die russischen Truppen
in der Ukraine ein.
Ich habe heute eine militärische
Spezialoperation angeordnet.
Die Welt veränderte sich -
auch für mich als Journalist.
Marina im überwachten russischen
Grenzgebiet noch einmal zu besuchen,
scheint mir zu heikel.
Mein russischer Kameramann Evgeny
fährt allein hin
und nimmt für mich das Interview auf.
Ich selbst
melde mich über Videotelefon.
* Klingeln *
Guten Tag, Marina.
Guten Tag, Christof.
Gruss aus Russland.
Schnell wird klar:
Marina ist nicht mehr die Gleiche
wie im letzten Herbst.
Russlands schärfste Waffe,
die Fernsehpropaganda,
scheint voll zugeschlagen zu haben.
Als man uns das alles gezeigt
und ausführlich erzählt hat,
wie das gewesen ist,
haben wir natürlich
einen Schock gekriegt.
Ich habe so viel Fernsehen geschaut.
Für einen normalen Menschen ist es
unerträglich, so was anzuschauen:
die Gräueltaten,
die die ukrainischen Nazis dort
gegenüber der Zivilbevölkerung
begehen,
wie sie Kinder töten.
Warum beschiessen sie die Wohnhäuser
und zerstören
die ganze Infrastruktur?
Das ist doch die Taktik
der verbrannten Erde.
Man ruft alle auf,
gegen Putin zu kämpfen -
auch mithilfe der Hexerei.
Man trommelt dort alle Hexen
zum Hexensabbat zusammen,
damit sie hexen
und so gegen Putin kämpfen.
Für mich ist das ein klares Zeichen.
Marina, aber ...
Darum haben wir uns alle
um den Präsidenten vereinigt
und unterstützen ihn.
Ich bete für unseren Präsidenten,
damit er genug Kraft und Gesundheit
hat, alles in Ordnung zu bringen,
damit endlich der Frieden kommt.
Sie wissen aber, dass wir ein
ganz anderes Bild vom Krieg haben.
Ja, ein ganz anderes Bild.
Was wir und unsere Kollegen
dort vor Ort sehen,
was wir bei uns im Fernsehen zeigen,
das ist ein ganz anderer Krieg ...
Christof, ich möchte etwas sagen.
Entschuldigen Sie die Unterbrechung.
Würden Ihre Kollegen zeigen,
was in Wirklichkeit vorgeht,
würden sie ihren Job verlieren.
Entschuldigen Sie,
dass ich Ihnen das jetzt sagen muss,
aber Sie zeigen Russland
als Aggressor.
Sie würden doch nie
so etwas zeigen wie den Film,
der hier vor Kurzem rauskam:
"Marina, die Storchen-Mutter" -
über mich, über gute Menschen.
Dieser Film
würde im Westen nie gezeigt.
Aber wir haben Sie doch als
einen wunderbaren Menschen gezeigt,
so wie Sie sind.
- Ja, ja ...
Wir haben gezeigt, wie Sie sagen,
dass die Störche
ein Symbol des Friedens sind,
dass sie überall hinfliegen
und keine Grenzen haben
und dass die Menschen
auch so sein sollten.
Ich möchte,
dass die Menschen in Frieden leben.
Marina, aber Sie wissen bestimmt:
Nach UNO-Angaben sind bereits
etwa 400 Kinder ums Leben gekommen.
Ja, der Preis ist hoch. Zweifellos.
Aber ich bin heute stolz.
Ich bin stolz, dass Russland den
Donbass unter seine Fittiche nahm.
Der Krieg wird nicht
gegen die Ukraine geführt,
er findet nur
auf ukrainischem Territorium statt.
Russland kämpft allein
gegen den vereinten Westen.
Verzeihung, aber so ist es.
Sie wollten unsere Regierung
beseitigen und eine neue einsetzen.
Eine Regierung, die das tut,
was der Westen von ihr verlangt.
Wir brauchen diese Kliniken
für Geschlechtsumwandlung nicht -
Transgender,
Schwulencommunity usw.
Wir brauchen das nicht, was jetzt
in Europa so bunt aufblüht.
Wir wollen
keine gleichgeschlechtlichen Ehen.
Wir wollen nicht, dass es
Elternteil 1 und Elternteil 2 gibt.
Wir kämpfen dafür, dass Kinder
einen Vater und eine Mutter haben.
So ist es. Tut mir leid.
Sie meinen,
Sie führen den Krieg in der Ukraine,
damit ein Kind Vater und Mutter hat?
Damit Kinder in Russland
Vater und Mutter haben.
Wo ist der Zusammenhang zwischen
dem Krieg und Mama und Papa?
Die Gebiete, die Russland bereits
eingenommen hat, gehören Russland.
Die Ukraine
hat diese Gebiete verloren.
Russland hat seine Grenzen
wieder hergestellt.
Es hat sich den Donbass
und die Krim zurückgeholt.
Diese perversen Teufelswerte
aus dem Westen
wollten auch bei uns eindringen,
zusammen mit dem Liberalismus.
Gott sei Dank, gibt es jetzt
einen Eisernen Vorhang.
So werden wir
nichts dergleichen haben.
Wir hoffen, dass Russland
sich von den Knien erhebt
und die Industrie
wieder aufgebaut wird.
Ich komme wieder mal
persönlich vorbei,
wenn ihr nicht
einen Eisernen Vorhang baut.
Also die Chinesische Mauer
werden wir nicht errichten.
Ich würde mich
über Ihren Besuch freuen.
Tut mir leid,
dass ich so emotional wurde.
Aus der friedvollen Storchen-Frau
wurde eine glühende Verfechterin
von Putins Angriffskrieg.
In ihrem Bekanntenkreis seien bereits
getötete Soldaten beerdigt worden,
sagte sie.
Ich frage mich: Erklärt das auch ein
wenig ihren radikalen Sinneswandel?
Neben dem Fernsehen traut Marina
den Priestern der orthodoxen Kirche.
Bereits letzten Herbst
waren wir im Kloster Petschory,
nahe der Grenze zu Estland,
und haben dort gehört,
welche Ideen man hier predigt.
Leiter des Klosters
ist Bischof Tichon.
Er gilt als Beichtvater Putins.
Bei unserem Besuch
leitete er gerade eine Zeremonie.
Der junge Mann
opfert vier Haarsträhnen,
um in ein höheres Amt
aufgenommen zu werden.
Allmächtiger Gott,
erwähle deinen Diener.
* Kirchlicher Gesang *
Bischof Tichon
wollte uns keine Audienz gewähren.
Aber dass er zum konservativen Flügel
der orthodoxen Kirche gehört,
bestätigt sich bald im Gespräch mit
seinem Stellvertreter, Dekan Prochor.
Auch er ein Mann, der die Kreml-Linie
vertritt, wenn es darum geht,
wie Russland
die letzten 30 Jahre erlebt hat.
Alle haben gesagt: "Freiheit!"
Wissen Sie, das Wort Freiheit
ist ein grauenvolles Wort.
Frei sein wovon? Welche Freiheit
wurde uns angekündigt?
Freiheit, Sünden zu begehen?
Der Mensch ist Sklave der Sünde.
Im Evangelium steht:
"Christus kam zu uns und sagte:
"Ich bin gekommen,
um euch zu befreien
von der Sklaverei der Sünde."
Und in den 90er-Jahren wurde
dem sowjetischen Menschen gesagt:
"Alles, was verboten war,
ist jetzt erlaubt."
Schauen Sie, fast die ganze junge
Generation liegt auf dem Friedhof.
Und warum?
Alkohol, Drogen - alles ist erlaubt,
auch
unkontrollierte Sexverhältnisse.
Wir haben diese Generation verloren.
Sie meinen in den 90er-Jahren?
- Ja.
Und was änderte danach?
Was geändert hat?
Sehr viel.
Stabilität. Stabilität.
Die Grenze zu Estland
ist hier ganz nahe.
Wie sind die Beziehungen
zum Nachbarn?
Ich würde sagen, die Beziehungen
sind immer besser geworden, bis ...
... bis vor Kurzem.
Seit etwas weniger als zehn Jahren
gehen die Kontakte
mit Vollgas runter.
Es waren gute Beziehungen.
Esten kamen zu uns.
In Petschory
gibt es eine estnische Schule,
Kinder lernen Estnisch.
Warum haben sich
die Beziehungen verschlechtert?
Ich weiss nicht. Vielleicht wird
ihnen hinter der Grenze erzählt,
dass wir schlechte Menschen seien.
Aus irgendeinem Grund
haben sich die Verhältnisse
genau von der anderen Seite
verschlechtert.
Ein russisches Sprichwort besagt:
"Willst du Frieden,
bereite dich auf den Krieg vor."
Die Militärübungen dort
haben doch einen Grund.
All die Luftfahrtshows,
Demonstrationen der Militärtechnik -
wir verstehen schon,
dass das vielleicht
nur eine Abschreckung ist,
aber die grösste Abschreckung
ist der Herrgott und sein Werk.
Das Kloster betet jeden Tag.
Wie oft am Tag, Jefemij?
- Dreimal.
Wir beten dreimal am Tag -
für den Frieden auf der ganzen Welt.
Sie beten für den Frieden,
aber unterstützen den Krieg.
Diese Bilder
stammen aus dem Jahre 2022,
nur wenige Tage nach Kriegsbeginn.
Eine Predigt von Kyrill,
dem Oberhaupt
der russisch-orthodoxen Kirche.
Möge Gott verhindern, dass in der
derzeitigen politischen Situation
die uns nahestehende
brüderliche Ukraine
in eine Richtung gelenkt wird,
wo die bösen Kräfte,
die seit jeher
gegen die Einheit Russlands
und der russischen Kirche kämpfen,
die Oberhand gewinnen.
Auf den ersten Blick ganz unpolitisch
war 2021 meine nächste Begegnung -
mit einem bekannten
russischen Käseproduzenten.
Hallo, ist das hier das Geschäft?
Guten Tag.
Woher kommen Sie?
- Wir sind aus Moskau.
Wir sind aus der Schweiz.
Wir kamen extra wegen des Käses.
- Sehr gut.
Guten Tag, Dmitry. Freut mich.
Wie macht man es hier? Wir tragen
meistens Masken und sind geimpft.
Wir sind auch geimpft.
Das ist übrigens ein Schweizer Käse:
Belper Knolle.
Wie?
- Belper Knolle.
Knolle?
- Ja, Knolle.
Ist der importiert?
- Nein, den machen wir selber.
Ich würde gerne wissen,
ob er ähnlich schmeckt
wie der in der Schweiz.
Ein feines Stück.
Mmh. Oh.
Bravo.
Das ist Ksjuscha, meine Frau.
Guten Tag, sehr angenehm.
- Guten Tag.
Man sagt,
in Russland gebe es nur Öl und Gas,
aber es gibt auch solche Sachen.
Öl und Gas sind nicht in Russland,
sondern bei denen,
und bei uns gibt es den Rest.
Wir trennen das.
Bei "denen"? Wer ist das?
- Das sind die da oben, unser Olymp.
Es gibt Russland
und es gibt die Regierung.
Es gab übrigens
einen guten sowjetischen Film -
Sie kennen ihn bestimmt -, in dem es
einen treffenden Spruch gab:
"Die Regierung lebt bei uns
auf einem anderen Planeten."
Schnell merkte ich: Dmitry
ist ein interessanter Zeitgenosse.
Ehemalige Studienkollegen
haben Spitzenposten
in der russischen Regierung.
Mit ihnen habe er
keinen Kontakt mehr.
Er sei zwar Patriot,
aber auch Kritiker der Regierung.
Z.B. störe es ihn, dass Gasleitungen
in den Westen führten,
der Ort selbst aber
keinen Gasanschluss habe.
Im Hotelzimmer, nach der Begegnung,
schaute ich mir
russisches Fernsehen an.
* Russische TV-Berichterstattung *
Schon vor Beginn des Ukraine-Krieges
fühlte es sich an
wie in einer Parallelwelt.
Der Tenor: Russland wird bedroht -
und zwar vom Westen.
Das Volk muss zusammenstehen,
Oppositionelle sind Verräter.
* Russische TV-Berichterstattung *
Was macht diese Dauerbeschallung
mit Kriegsrhetorik mit den Menschen?
Glauben sie
an den bösen Feind im Westen?
Ich traf mich nochmals
mit Käser Dmitry.
Bei meinen früheren Reisen
vor ein paar Jahren -
immer, wenn von Putin gesprochen
wurde, haben die Leute gesagt:
"Ja, das Leben ist schwer,
aber wir respektieren Putin,
weil er gegen Amerika kämpft."
Für seine Aussenpolitik
wurde er respektiert,
aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
Ja, genau, für seine Aussenpolitik.
Ich glaube,
das ist eine typische Antwort.
Man sagt bei uns:
"Ja, es geht uns schlecht,
aber dafür hat man
auf der ganzen Welt Angst vor uns."
"Ohne Hosen, aber dafür mit Hut."
* Christof lacht. *
Aber das, was erzählt wird -
dass die NATO Russland angreifen
könnte oder Russland das Baltikum -,
ist das hier ein Thema
für die Menschen?
Ja, das ist ein Thema.
Ich kenne Leute, die haben
vielleicht nicht gerade Angst,
aber sie warten auf etwas.
Leute,
die die staatlichen Sender schauen.
* Handyklingeln *
Ah, der hier ist gerade einer davon.
Wir treffen uns jede Woche
in der Sauna, und jedes Mal sagt er:
"Morgen beginnt der Krieg.
Damit du vorbereitet bist."
Und ich sage ihm:
"Wunderbar, ich bin bereit."
Und er glaubt das wirklich?
- Ja, die glauben das.
Paranoia war hier im Grenzgebiet
schon im Herbst 2021 spürbar.
Bei Aufnahmen im Zentrum
wurde unser Kameramann Evgeny
auf einmal von einem Beamten in Zivil
beschattet.
Evgeny rief uns an, wir sollten im
Auto bleiben, er würde sich melden.
Kurz danach wurde er
auf den Polizeiposten gebracht
und war nicht mehr erreichbar.
Unangenehme Momente,
insbesondere hier im Grenzgebiet.
Nach 2 Std. war er wieder draussen.
Dass ein Kameramann verhaftet wird,
nur weil er im Zentrum
ein Lenin-Denkmal filmt,
das überraschte mich dann doch.
Wir machten uns schnellstmöglich
aus dem Staub.
Macht das nichts,
dass ich in Blau-Gelb gekleidet bin?
Ich könnte ja angeklagt werden.
Soll ich hier oder hier sitzen?
Zuerst möchte ich Sie fragen:
Können Sie überhaupt
frei und offen reden
über Ihre Meinung
zur Situation in der Ukraine?
Ich kann verhüllt reden, aber jeder
kann dann verstehen, was ich meine.
Damit man mich nicht wegen
Falschinformation bestrafen kann.
Wir haben ja neue Gesetze.
Bei uns kann jetzt kann niemand mehr
ruhig offen reden. Leider.
Aber was ich sagen kann, sage ich.
Spürt man das in der Gesellschaft,
dass man nicht mehr
offen reden kann?
Klar spürt man das, ohne Frage.
Und wie?
Zu uns kommen viele Menschen.
Das Publikum, das Käse mag, das
sind meistens kultivierte Menschen.
Und 99 % von ihnen sehen die
Situation derzeit ähnlich wie ich.
Was bei allen fast gleich war:
der grosse Schock
und die Ungewissheit,
wie man weiterleben soll.
Was passiert in der Ukraine,
was meinen Sie?
Ein Albtraum.
Ein Horror.
Unglaublich.
Nichts Gutes.
Warum gibt es Menschen wie Sie,
die das verstehen, und andere nicht?
Die Menschen
sind einfach unterschiedlich.
Das ist alles.
Es ist bemerkenswert:
Nach diesen - sagen wir - Februar-
Ereignissen hat sich alles geteilt.
Die Welt
hat sich in zwei Teile geteilt.
Es gibt diejenigen,
welche Mitleid haben,
und solche, die blind der Propaganda
folgen und nicht mehr nachdenken.
Es gibt nicht diese feste Abgrenzung
zwischen Russen und Nicht-Russen.
Vielmehr jene, die den Schmerz
der anderen Menschen spüren können,
und jene, die das nicht können.
So ist es.
Ich wusste nicht,
wie ich weiterleben soll.
Ehrlich gesagt, habe ich
gleich angefangen, zu telefonieren
und mich erkundigt,
wie wir ausreisen können.
Das war mein erster Gedanke:
"Man muss dringend,
dringend, dringend abreisen,
um nicht Komplize von diesem Unfug
zu werden."
Ich habe an die Deutschen während
des Zweiten Weltkrieges gedacht,
die auch gegen den Krieg
gewesen sind.
Ich hatte vorher nie
solche Gedanken.
Für mich waren immer alle
Deutschen - Verzeihung - Faschisten.
Das war natürlich
sowjetische Propaganda.
Aber jetzt
beginnst du zu realisieren,
dass es doch auch andere gab,
die gegen die damalige
"Spezialoperation" waren.
Und dann hatte ich
einen anderen Gedanken:
"Warum sollen wir ausreisen
und nicht sie?"
"Sie sollen doch
aus dem Land abhauen."
Sie? Wer ist das?
Sie - das ist unser Olymp,
Zentrum der Entscheidungsfindung,
wie man heute zu sagen pflegt.
Ich hoffe,
dass Russland jetzt nicht insgesamt
als böse wahrgenommen wird,
sondern nur einzelne Personen -
die Leitung des Landes,
die das macht, was sie jetzt macht.
Es ist nur diese Hoffnung geblieben,
dass man uns nicht allesamt hasst
und als Faschisten bezeichnet.
Ksjuscha.
Ihre Frau macht sich Sorgen.
Ja, sie macht sich Sorgen.
Dann kam im September 2021
der Moment, Russland Adieu zu sagen.
Eine Brücke führt von der
russischen Grenzstadt Iwangorod
zur estnischen Grenzstadt Narva.
Dort ist EU- und NATO-Land.
Problemlos passierte ich damals
die Grenze zu Fuss.
Ich wollte wissen, wie die Menschen
auf der europäischen Seite
auf ihren russischen Nachbarn
schauen.
Die estnische Stadt Narva
ist russisch geprägt.
Für die hiesigen Industriebetriebe
wurden während der Sowjetzeit
Arbeiter aus ganz Russland geholt.
95 % der Menschen
sprechen noch Russisch,
gut ein Drittel
hat den russischen Pass.
Welchen Pass haben Sie?
- Einen estnischen.
Bedauern Sie,
keinen russischen Pass zu haben?
Nein, ich bin sehr zufrieden hier.
Es ist eine russische Stadt
mit europäischem Flair.
Eine bessere Version von Russland
vielleicht.
Möchten Sie nicht in Russland leben?
- Nein, ich hätte dort Angst.
Wenn dir dort etwas passiert,
dann weisst du nicht,
wohin und was du tun sollst.
Hier hast du das Gesetz und weisst,
an wen du dich wenden kannst.
Das ist meine Meinung.
Diese junge Frau war gerade dabei,
für die Bürgermeisterkandidatin
Katri Raik Wahlwerbung zu machen.
Die Wahl hat Raik gewonnen.
Im Juli 2022
treffe ich sie dann persönlich.
Ich brauche noch 3 Min.
- Okay, dann setze ich mich wieder.
Kein Problem.
- Bleiben wir hier?
Oder gehen wir irgendwo hin?
- Was Ihnen lieber ist.
Sie können uns auch gerne
etwas von der Stadt zeigen.
Wenn Sie Zeit haben.
- Okay, ich mache das zu Ende,
dann schauen wir.
Wir können auch zum Fluss gehen,
wo wir sitzen
und nach Russland schauen können.
Das ist vielleicht
auch für Sie schöner.
Okay.
Nach Russland zu schauen
ist immer schön.
5 Min.
- Okay.
Russland.
- Ja, Russland.
Friedlich.
- So sieht es aus.
Gibt es noch gemeinsame Projekte?
Nein, die wurden alle gestoppt.
Soweit ich weiss, ist alles,
was mit Russland verbunden ist, zu.
Seit dem 24. Februar
kommt es niemandem mehr in den Sinn,
etwas gemeinsam zu machen.
Gemeinsame Projekte
sind also kein Thema mehr?- Nein.
Und wie geht es Ihnen so,
jetzt mit dem Krieg?
Es ist schwer.
- Schwer?- Ja.
Aber ...
Und niemand weiss,
wann es zu Ende gehen wird,
was das Ende bedeuten wird
und wie es dann weitergeht.
Vielleicht nehmen wir ein Bier?
- Ja, gerne.
Darf ich?
- Ja.
Aber darf ich einladen?
Ja, gut, freut mich.
Gesundheit.
- Zum Wohl!- Zum Wohl!
Jetzt ist der russische
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine:
Auf welcher Seite
stehen die Menschen in Narva?
Das ist sehr schwer zu sagen.
Am Anfang schwiegen alle.
Niemand wollte sich dazu äussern.
Ich kenne viele Personen, die
in ihren Familien vereinbart haben,
nicht über den Krieg zu sprechen.
Man redet nicht darüber.
- Ja, genau.
Der Anteil
der offenkundigen Putin-Anhänger
liegt vielleicht bei 10-20 %.
Die Hälfte der Bevölkerung
ist vielleicht mehr pro Putin.
Und dann gibt es
vielleicht noch 30 %, die verstehen,
dass der Krieg in der Ukraine
unser gemeinsamer Krieg ist.
"Gemeinsamer Krieg" -
in welchem Sinne?
Für uns ist sehr wichtig,
dass die Ukraine gewinnt.
Sie haben den Krieg,
um uns zu schützen.
Denn wenn nicht die Ukraine,
dann könnten es auch wir sein.
Aber so denkt hier die Minderheit?
Ja, die Minderheit denkt so.
Wir arbeiten jeden Tag, machen
jeden Tag einen kleinen Schritt,
um den Menschen zu zeigen, dass ...
... dass es hier
wirklich sicher ist.
Aber sicher ist es hier mit der NATO
und der Europäischen Union.
Es ist hier sicher,
wenn wir Mitglied
der zwei grossen Familien sind.
Sie spüren also
keine Unsicherheit oder Angst?
Angst nicht, Unsicherheit ...
Die Unsicherheit darüber,
was morgen kommt,
muss im Moment
jeder Mensch in Europa haben.
Alle.
Was bedeutet der Krieg in
der Ukraine für Narva und Iwangorod?
Für die Beziehung
zwischen dieser estnischen Stadt
und der russischen Nachbarstadt?
Im Moment gibt es keine Beziehungen.
Ich habe seit Kriegsbeginn
den Bürgermeister von Iwangorod
nicht mehr gesprochen.
Wieso machen Sie nicht
den ersten Schritt und rufen mal an?
Der Kopf erlaubt es nicht.
Es geht nicht?
- Nein, es geht nicht mehr.
Krieg ist
ein sehr schwarz-weisses Ding.
Schwarz
ist die Russische Föderation.
Es ist ganz, ganz klar.
Und hierbei ...
Hierbei gibt es null Toleranz.
Ehrlich.
Auch in näherer Zukunft nicht?
Nein.
Das war eindeutig.
Guten Abend, Frau Bürgermeisterin.
- Guten Abend.
Abends in einem Strandhotel
ausserhalb von Narva.
* Melodisches, estnisches Lied *
Die junge Frau, die hier singt,
ist die Wahlkämpferin von damals.
Hauptberuflich ist sie Musikerin.
Draussen dachten wir zuerst,
es sei Ihr Auto,
das auf uns zufährt.
Ich schaue
und sehe eine blonde Frau.
Dann winke ich ihr zu und merke,
es sind ja gar nicht Sie.
Hat sie gewinkt?
- Ja, hat sie.
Eine freundliche Frau.
Wir sprachen am Strand
mit den Menschen
über die Situation in der Ukraine.
Plötzlich kam es zu einem Streit.
Ah ja?
Verzichtet hier in der Bar
besser auf solche Gespräche.
Darf man das nicht?
Wozu? Jemand hört etwas
und fängt an, zu agitieren,
propagandieren usw.
Das wird als schmerzhaft empfunden.
Ja, am Strand war es gleich.
Aber das hier
ist ein privates Unternehmen.
Am Strand ist es schon okay,
da ist das öffentliche Leben,
aber hier ist fremdes Territorium.
Haben Sie hier
manchmal Angst vor dem Krieg
angesichts
der Ereignisse in der Ukraine?
Nein, einmal hat Putin angedeutet,
dass das Baltikum
als Nächstes auf der Liste stehe.
Wir sind dann etwas erschrocken.
Nein, uns muss man nicht retten.
Es ist alles gut hier.
Aber so wirklich Angst
spüre ich nicht.
Es ist schon möglich,
dass etwas passiert,
aber das ist nur eine Möglichkeit.
So richtig Panik oder Angst
gibt es nicht.
Es ist einfach so:
Bevor der Krieg
in der Ukraine ausbrach,
fragte ich meine Bekannten dort oft:
"Bereitet ihr euch
auf einen Krieg vor?"
Aber die meisten sagten:
"Nein, es passiert doch nichts."
Also wir schliessen
diese Möglichkeit nicht aus,
aber wir haben keine Panik.
Wenn was ist,
wissen wir schon, was zu tun ist.
Wir haben ja jetzt ein Beispiel.
Einige Menschen fangen schon an,
sich vorzubereiten -
suchen Luftschutzkeller,
graben auf ihren Datschen Bunker.
Das gibt es schon seit Längerem.
Das sind Menschen,
die vom Typ her einfach immer
besorgt oder unruhig sind.
Aber in der Stadt generell
gibt es keine Panik.
Hätte Russland hier
wieder einen grösseren Einfluss,
würde es viele Menschen im Baltikum
hart treffen.
Der Unabhängigkeitskampf
gegen die Sowjetunion
steckt noch tief
im kollektiven Gedächtnis.
Was am 23. August 1989 in den drei
baltischen Staaten Estland, Lettland
und Litauen passiert ist,
weiss im Baltikum jedes Kind:
Die Menschen
bildeten eine 600 km lange Kette
durch alle drei Länder hindurch.
Über 2 Mio. Menschen demonstrierten
Hand in Hand für ihren Traum:
die Unabhängigkeit
von der Sowjetunion.
Der Höhepunkt
eines jahrelangen Kampfes.
Der Kampf war erfolgreich:
Litauen erklärte 1990
die Unabhängigkeit,
Lettland und Estland folgten 1991.
2004 traten alle drei Länder
der EU und der NATO bei.
Bei meinem Besuch im Herbst 2021
verliess ich Narva in Richtung
estnische Hauptstadt Tallinn.
Estland ist sehr ländlich geprägt.
Viele Menschen
zieht es in die boomende Hauptstadt.
Hier lebt rund ein Drittel
der Bevölkerung des Landes.
In einem Aussenquartier der Stadt
traf ich mich mit der Familie Villig.
Reet Villig
war eine der treibenden Kräfte
im Unabhängigkeitskampf der Esten.
Tochter Maia-Liisa
war als Kind an den Demos oft dabei.
Selbstverständlich
auch in der Menschenkette.
Jedes Mal, wenn wir
an diesem Ort vorbeifahren,
ein Bauernhaus in einer Kurve,
sagt jemand im Auto:
"Hier standen wir."
Ich denke,
jede Familie erinnert sich daran.
Dass Estland zwei Jahre nach diesem
denkwürdigen Tag unabhängig würde,
hatte sie damals
noch nicht zu träumen gewagt.
Es war der 16. Oktober 1992,
ein Jahr nach der Unabhängigkeit,
als ich meinen ersten
estnischen Pass bekam.
Und wie war es?
Es war: "Wow!"
"Der estnische Pass, endlich."
Es war wie ein Traum.
Aber wir hatten immer gewusst:
"Eines Tages wird es passieren."
Tief im Herzen wusste jeder:
"Es muss geschehen."
"So kann es nicht weitergehen."
"Wir können nicht ewig
unter diesem Sowjetregime leben."
Ich erinnere mich an den Tag,
als ich merkte,
dass etwas anders ist.
Das war 1985,
als Gorbatschow gewählt wurde.
Sie zeigten es im Fernsehen.
Mutter und Vater schrien:
"Sie haben ihn gewählt,
sie haben ihn tatsächlich gewählt!"
Ich verstand es nicht ganz.
Da war dieser Typ
mit diesem Ding an seiner Stirn,
alles war auf Russisch ...
Aber ich erinnere mich
an diesen Moment.
Das Gefühl, dass die Russen erneut
kommen könnten, ist das noch da?
Wir haben Angst.
- Jeden Tag.
Etwa vor zehn Jahren machte ich
in Brüssel eine Ausbildung,
mit jungen Menschen aus ganz Europa.
Ein Däne versuchte mir zu erklären,
dass wir Esten paranoid seien
wegen der Russen.
Da erklärte ich ihm:
"Mein Haus ist 80 km
von der russischen Grenze entfernt."
"Ich habe noch zwölf Jahre,
um meine Hypothek abzubezahlen."
"Wenn ich die Geschichte Estlands
anschaue,
gibt es keinen Grund, zu glauben,
dass ich jemals schuldenfrei
in meinem Haus leben kann."
"Die Geschichte lehrt uns eher,
dass die Russen kommen,
bevor ich meine Hypothek
zurückbezahlt habe."
Viele wundern sich,
weshalb wir so glücklich sind,
NATO-Truppen in Estland zu haben.
Aber das ist unsere Versicherung.
Der Versicherung
begegneten wir dann tatsächlich auch.
Kurz nachdem wir die Grenze
zu Lettland überquert hatten,
trafen wir zufällig
auf eine Übung von NATO-Staaten.
* Schüsse *
Ui, ui, ui.
Ist das eine NATO-Übung
oder eine baltische?
Es ist ...
Wir haben
die lettische Nationalgarde,
zusammen mit Gästen aus Dänemark,
Estland und ...
Ah, sehr gut. Vielen Dank.
Nach dem russischen Einmarsch
in die Ukraine
wurde hier das Truppenkontingent
der NATO nochmals aufgestockt.
Während in der Ukraine
der Krieg tobt,
ist es am Stadtrand von Tallinn
friedlich.
Hallo, hallo.
Willkommen.
- Wie geht es?
Alles gut?
- Ja.
Willkommen
in unserem halb verbrannten Garten.
Er ist wunderbar.
Als wir uns letztes Jahr trafen,
hatten Sie etwas Angst davor,
was geschehen könnte.
Haben Sie jetzt mehr Angst
vor Russland als früher?
Einerseits ja, andererseits nein.
Die russische Invasion
in der Ukraine zeigt,
dass es
keine rationale Analyse mehr gibt,
die Russlands Vorgehen
erklären könnte.
Man muss also
auf alles gefasst sein -
auch
auf einen weiteren sinnlosen Krieg.
Andererseits ist es so:
Die grossen russischen Verluste
in der Ukraine
haben die Wahrscheinlichkeit
für einen Angriff reduziert -
zumindest in den nächsten Jahren.
Es gibt jetzt diesen Witz
in Estland:
"Wir sind so sicher
wie seit Jahren nicht mehr."
Die Russen haben in der Stadt Pskow
Elitetruppen.
Diese sollen angeblich bis zu 60 %
ausgeschaltet worden sein.
Einer unserer hohen Verteidigungs-
beamten wies darauf hin,
dass wir
eines der ersten Länder waren,
die Waffen in die Ukraine
geliefert haben,
sogar vor der Invasion.
Und der Beamte sagte:
"Wir haben diese Waffen gekauft,
um russische Panzer
in die Luft zu jagen."
"Wenn die Ukrainer
diese Waffen brauchen,
um russische Panzer zu zerstören,
dann haben diese Waffen
ihren Zweck erfüllt."
Wie nehmen Sie hier
die unterschiedlichen Reaktionen
von West- und Osteuropa wahr?
Z.B. von Deutschland oder Frankreich
und den baltischen Staaten
oder Polen?
Ein Stück weit sind wir enttäuscht.
V.a. wegen ihrer
zurückhaltenden Reaktionen.
Diese ganzen Telefonate
zwischen Putin und Macron
oder Putin und Scholz usw.
Man sprach doch auch nicht
mit Saddam Hussein.
Also auch nicht mit Putin.
Für uns ist Putin
wie Saddam Hussein oder Hitler.
Für uns ist das leicht zu verstehen.
Warum verstehen die das nicht?
Sie sagen, dass es am Schluss
eine politische Lösung geben werde,
deshalb müsse man
mit Putin sprechen.
Es kann keine politische Lösung
geben,
bei der die Ukraine
Territorium abgeben muss.
Denn wenn sie verfolgen und wissen,
was in den von Russland
besetzten Gebieten geschieht ...
Das kann Europa nicht akzeptieren.
Es geschieht dort dasselbe
wie hier in Estland
zu Zeiten der Sowjetunion.
Wenn man den Russen
freie Hand lässt,
könnten sie auch uns
in fünf Jahren wieder attackieren,
wenn sie damit jetzt durchkommen.
Können Sie die Schweizer Position
verstehen, die neutral ist,
auch wenn jetzt bei uns
Anpassungen diskutiert werden?
Ganz klar: Nein!
Wenn du hier neutral bist,
dann unterstützt du den Bösewicht -
v.a., wenn Neutralität heisst,
andere daran zu hindern,
den Guten zu helfen.
Wenn du neutral bist,
dann sei es auch,
behindere aber andere nicht.
In welchem Sinn?
Die Schweiz hindert angeblich
andere Länder daran,
in der Schweiz fabrizierte Waffen
in die Ukraine zu liefern.
Das ist nicht neutral.
Die Idee dahinter ist,
keine Waffen in ein Land zu liefern,
das gerade Krieg führt.
Das ist
eine sehr komfortable Haltung,
wenn du im Zentrum Europas lebst.
Wir können uns diesen Luxus
hier nicht leisten.
Bedrückend.
Dieses Wort beschreibt
wohl am ehesten die Atmosphäre,
die ich auf meinen Reisen
auf beiden Seiten der Grenze erlebte.
Selbst, wo im Herbst 2021 noch
versöhnliche Töne zu vernehmen waren,
scheint der Eiserne Vorhang
in den Köpfen vieler Menschen
immer mehr zugezogen zu werden.
Die Russen,
die nicht einverstanden sind,
können nichts tun,
ausser zu schweigen
oder das Land zu verlassen.
In den baltischen Ländern
geraten die Menschen nicht in Panik.
Die Härte ihrer Aussagen
verdeutlicht aber:
Der Nachbar ist ihnen unheimlich.
Eine latente Bedrohung schwebt
ständig in und über ihren Köpfen.
Ich fahre zurück in die Schweiz
im Schosse Europas.
Als Korrespondent
versuchte ich jahrelang,
einen bescheidenen Beitrag
zu leisten,
um die Gräben zwischen Russland
und dem Westen zu verkleinern.
Jetzt sind sie wieder tiefer denn je.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022